et il est porte parole du rassemblement
national député du nord bonjour
sébastien chenu bonjour alors nous
sommes d'ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour parler de divers sujets et on va
commencer par le plan de relance du
secteur automobile qui doit être
dévoilée aujourd'hui par le président de
la république
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs ils valent
dévoilé dans votre région à léo de
france à étaples alors qu'est ce que
vous attendez de ce plan de soutien au
secteur automobile
d'abord je voudrais avoir une pensée
pour les ouvriers de renault qui dans
notre région et dans notre département
du nord également sur les sites de doué
et de maubeuge s'inquiètent j'en parle
avec notre et du régional maubeugeois
hemeryck merlot qui misait
qu'effectivement il ya de l'inquiétude
pour l'avenir sur les sites qui ne sont
pas encore les quatre sites menacés
la problématique elle est la suivante
renault avoir beaucoup de difficultés à
redémarrer et a vu ses ventes baisser
très fortement que fait le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
en fait le gouvernement est dans
l'incantatoire il dit les aides
publiques ou le prêt garantie d'état
n'aura lieu que si renault maintient de
l'emploi je pense qu'il faut aller plus
loin
c'est un secteur stratégique il faut
protéger les emplois il faut aussi
rhodia redynamiser la marque
c'est ça à terme c'est à dire avoir un
champion automobile
or pour ça il faut repenser la stratégie
du constructeur est l'étape un levier il
est actionnaire il peut repenser la
stratégie avec des alliances
il faut exiger la protection des sites
français
aujourd'hui il ya une difficulté sur les
sites français parce que ce qui est
produit en france ce n'est pas ce qui se
vend le mieux chez renault l'état doit
pouvoir l'exigé je pense que c'est les
deux leviers alors sur renault ça veut
dire que vous demander le gel des
licenciements
aujourd'hui nous demandons que les sites
français ne soient pas ceux qui ferment
donc effectivement nous demandons qu'il
n'y ait pas de fermetures d'emplois sur
les sites français et renault doit
pouvoir à travers la capitale
repenser sa stratégie notamment et bien
bénéficié de la commande publique de
l'état
nous nous considérons qu'on doit faire
dans ces cas là du patriotisme
économique
l'état doit montrer l'exemple il doit
fléché sa commande pour renouveler le
parc notamment de voiture est bien de la
poste de la police etc
il doit aller vers le constructeur
français et puis faut repenser la
question des alliances c'est nécessaire
sinon les quatre sites que nous
connaissons en france donc le site
historique de flins ou celui de dieu
évidemment vont être durement impacté
mais ensuite ce seront ceux de doué de
maubeuge qui seront eux-mêmes impact et
moi j'habite d'ailleurs le président de
la république à venir à maubeuge il va
falloir un moment aussi rendre des
comptes devant les ouvriers ou c'est
carlos ghosn avait promis des millions
des centaines millions d'euros
d'investissements pour que ces sites
puissent se développer
où sont-ils l'état une exigence doit
avoir une exigence vis-à-vis du
constructeur donc vous demander une
commande publique ciblée sur les
constructeurs français
ah ben c'est à dire une commande
publique qui n'iraient pas à des
constructeurs japonais par exemple comme
toyota qui crée des emplois dans votre
région les autres lance l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre mais en ce qui concerne des
usines qui sont en difficulté décident
qu'ils sont en difficulté l'état
puisqu'il à 15% du capital doit pouvoir
faire ce patriotisme économique
même s'il et j'allais dire momentanée il
doit montrer l'exemple on peut pas juste
dire arnaud ne supprimez pas d'emploi
pointent la ligne bleue et dans
l'incantatoire l'état doit montrer qu'il
pèse et il publie à cette stratégie est
repensée je pense que c'est la clé pour
sauver renault
alors parlons de ce plan de relance de
l'ensemble du secteur automobile on a
déjà les premières pistes de ce plan il
y aurait une hausse de la prime à la
casse pour acheter une voiture récente
une hausse également du bonus écologique
pour acheter des voitures plus propres
est-ce qu'il faut un virage écologique
dans le secteur automobile oui bien sûr
il faut repenser également tout ce qui
est la politique lié aux batteries et à
la consommation de véhicules électriques
je pense qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin on sait qu'on est très dépendant de
l'asie sur la capacité à construire des
batteries avec des métaux rares on les a
pas ici
eh bien je pense qu'il va falloir que
renault notamment développe la filière
hydrogène beaucoup plus et investissent
là dedans
or on sait que renault était très
réticent a été très réticent à cela là
encore ça fait partie de la stratégie
dans lequel l'état doit pouvoir
actionner ce levier doit pouvoir s'en
mêler oui renault doit avoir une
stratégie qui aille vers l'écologie qui
aille vers l'hydrogène qui aille vers
l'électrique c'est à ce prix là qu'on
pourra sauver ce champion français alors
globalement pour éviter la casse sociale
dans nos entreprises
en france on est vu que le chômage
partiel pendant deux mois avait limité
cette casse au mois de juin le
gouvernement nous a dit hier enfin en
tout cas a annoncé qu'il y aurait un
retrait progressif de l'état pour
financer le chômage partiel les
entreprises vont devoir le financer à
hauteur de 15% c'est une bonne décision
selon vous alors attention moi je pense
qu'il faut
plutôt du cas par cas parce que vous
avez des entreprises qui s'inquiète on
le voit avec renault pour l'avenir et si
en plus on surcharge la barque en leur
disant ça va être à votre tour de
financer le chômage partiel
même pendant quelques mois ça va
alourdir la difficulté et puis à des
entreprises je pense aux pme et aux tpe
notamment dans l'hôtellerie dans le
tourisme à qui elles évidemment on subit
on eu des fermetures administratives et
pour lesquels l'état doit encore être au
rendez vous pendant quelques mois donc
je pense qu'il faut vraiment le cibler
les secteurs qui ont encore besoin du
soutien fort de l'état en chômage
partiel pendant quelques mois et ceux
qui peuvent petit à petit sans dégager
c'est plutôt de la dentelle j'allais
dire qu'il faut faire et ne pas avoir
une décision qui tombe comme ça du haut
jusqu'en bas et qui ne voient pas la
subtilité du terrain est ce que cette
relance sera européenne alors que la
commission européenne prépa prépare son
grand plan de relance de mille 1000
milliards d'euros pour relancer
l'économie mais ses relances il faut
qu'elle soit d'abord nationale parce que
les 500 milliards d'euros c'était le
plan tous les cas macro merkel vont être
aussi des milliards d'euros qui devront
être remboursés qui devront avoir en
écho des exigeants de répondre à des
exigences de l'union européenne
est ce que ça veut dire un impôt
européen à terre ou c'est moi j'ai été
très marqué par le fait que par exemple
la crds devait s'arrêter en 2023 c'est
cette contribution pour le remboursement
de la dette sociale
donc c'est un impôt en fait on est en
train de voir que finalement cet impôt
il va être pérennisée
on va continuer les français vont
continuer à le payer donc on voit bien
qu'il y a quand même derrière ce que
demande l'union européenne derrière ce
que fait ce gouvernement la tentation
quand même d'aller augmenter ou d'aller
pérenniser un certain nombre d'impôts
pour les français je crois qu'on ne
pourra pas en tous les cas relancer
notre économie en faisant supporter le
poids que celle ci aux français mais
comment on finance cette relance qui va
creuser les déficits et la dette
oui nous avons proposé à la création
d'un grand emprunt national qui sera
fléché par l'épargné des français avec
évidemment une mobilisation une capacité
à attirer l'épargné populaire des
français dans cet emprunt en leur
donnant par exemple les mêmes
intéressement que les ans que les boîtes
du cac 40 et donc à mobiliser l'épargné
des français elle est importante cette
épargne elle s'est d'ailleurs accru
pendant le coc vide et je pense que ce
grand emprunt national nous permettrait
effectivement d'abord de nous sentir
libre de pouvoir choisir nous français
là où nous voulons fléché
et bien cette épargne que nous aurions
cet emprunt que nous aurions levée
plutôt que de dépendre toujours de
l'union européenne d'autre m'a vu la
nullité allez on va parler du ségur de
la santé cette concertation qui s'est
ouvert hier avec les acteurs du monde
hospitalier pour améliorer les
conditions de travail de nos soignants
edouard philippe l'a dit il y aura des
hausses de salaire significatives pour
les soignants cela vous satisfait pas
seulement moi je suis toujours très
attentif à ce que dit le gouvernement
sur ce sujet parce que vous savez il
nous avait dit qu'il y aurait des primes
de 1500 euros pour les soignants et puis
on est en train de voir leur nous dans
le nord on a failli passer à la trappe
c'est à dire nos soignants ont failli
simplement avoir une prime de 500 euros
la mobilisation je dois le dire des
députés du rassemblement national du
pas-de-calais et de votre serviteur dans
le nord également d'autres élus locaux a
permis que cette prime soit évidemment
c'est demain distribués il faudra voir
également ce qu'elle est bien distribué
dans les ehpad et etc
mais je pense que l'idée de mieux
rémunérer nos soignants dans les
hôpitaux est un premier pas mais pas
seulement vous savez les hôpitaux ces
220 milliards à peu près on se demande
parfois où va l'argent
il y as forcément la nécessité de mieux
rémunéré de rendre plus attractive
ces professions mais je pense également
aux manipulateurs en radiologie au
brancardier enfin y'a pas que les
soignants direct et puis également la
nécessité d'augmenter le nombre de
soignants
on a appliqué les 35 heures à l'hôpital
mais on n'a pas augmenté le nombre de
personnel donc évidemment ça c'est un
deuxième levier et puis y en a plus
plusieurs repenser la t2a démédicalisé
remède qui remédie qu'alizé les
directions d'hôpitaux on a bien vu que
la haute administration et
l'administration avait été très
gourmande pendant toutes ces années
beaucoup d'argent public a été englouti
par engloutis par l'administratif donc
vous estimez que l'administration a trop
de poids dans le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital vous proposait de créer des
postes de soignants
il serait financé par des suppressions
de postes de fonctionnaires dans
l'hôpital non je pense qu'il y a des tas
de marge de manoeuvre que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui explorer alors
évidemment on voit bien que lorsque le
budget de l'hôpital augmente le budget
de la santé augmentent ils augmentent
peu il a baissé d'ailleurs ces dernières
années mais la seule augmentation qui a
pu exister c'était celle de lyme
l'aide médicale d'état on voit bien que
ça c'est pas supportable on voit bien
que des politiques qui n'ont peut être
explorées par exemple le prix du
médicament à l'unité il va falloir qu'on
aille dans cette direction là la fraude
sociale qui doit continuer à être
combattu tout autant d'ailleurs que la
fraude fiscale
là on a encore des marges et puis la
mobilisation du monde de l'assurance
moi j'attends que le monde de
l'assurance qui devrait fortement se
mobiliser pour épauler les collectivités
pour épauler l'état dans les plans de
relance et des îles pourraient être
mobilisés là aussi dans le cadre d'une
politique de la santé
donc on a des leviers il faudra traiter
ceci aussi avec un plan liés à la
médecine de ville
on peut pas uniquement traités l'hôpital
d'un côté faire comme si la médecine de
ville n'avait pas besoin de l'autre côté
d'un traitement alors cela fait deux
semaines que les français sont des cons
finis
progressivement il y aura une nouvelle
étape qui va être annoncé jeudi par le
premier ministre et il pourrait y avoir
un élargissement du rayon de 100km
d'autorisation d'autorisation pardon à
des déplacements dans chacun des
départements c'est une annonce qu'a fait
jean baptiste lemoyne le secrétaire
d'état au tourisme
est ce que cette décision serait bonne
ce qu'il faut relâcher le déconfinement
moi je crois qu'il faut de la cohérence
les français ils comprennent ils ont été
très disciplinés majoritairement pendant
cette crise du coc vide mais ils
comprennent les choses à partir du
moment où elles sont cohérentes
vous pouvez pas élargir la zone de
déplacement de 100 km si par exemple
vous n'ouvrez pas les parcs et les
jardins dans les grandes villes
c'est incohérent les gens ne
comprendraient pas qu'on puisse aller se
balader à 200 km sans profiter avec des
mesures sanitaires des processus très
précis les parcs et jardins
donc je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est de
la cohérence pas mentir aux français non
plus faut arrêter leur raconter qu'on
fait 700 mille tests alors que la
réalité est qu'on fait 300 mille tests
et qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus loin
dans les tests parce que sinon on va
avoir du relâchement et le relâchement
peut avoir évidemment des répercussions
graves sur sa donc une politique
cohérente et le gouvernement n'a quand
même beaucoup manqué alors demain il y
aura un débat à l'assemblée nationale
sur l'application stop qu'ovide
l'application de traçage numérique des
citoyens sur la base du volontariat pour
casser les chaînes de contamination
quelle va être la des lapereaux la
position des députés rassemblement
national nous ne sommes pas à qui stoppe
que vider à ce traçage pour j'allais
dire deux raisons techniques une raison
presque philosophique
raisons techniques les garanties
juridiques nous semble aujourd'hui
insuffisante
le stockage des données personnelles qui
sera dans les mains des gaffes à nous
semble poser de vraies questions sur
l'aspect juridique une question
technique
on sait bien que ce sont des processus
qui ne règle pas tout il faut que les
téléphones soient lus mais il faut du
volontariat il faut une proximité tout
ça techniquement ce n'est pas la panacée
non plus et puis une question d'ordre
philosophique est ce que c'est un pas de
plus vers la société que nous souhaitons
dans laquelle la traçabilité pourquoi
pas demain le puçage de l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens et bien aurait vocation
à être la règle
moi je reste très dubitatif sur ça alors
si jamais cette application est mise en
place par exemple le week-end prochain
est ce que vous pas personnellement
sébastien chenu vous téléchargerez cette
application stop qu'ovide non
aujourd'hui pour les raisons que je
viens de vous donner philosophie que
juridique technique
je ne suis pas disposé à donner
l'ensemble de mes données à faire en
sorte que l'ensemble de mes données
personnelles puissent transiter dans un
tuyau dont je ne connais pas finalement
la finalité très bien une question sur
la chloroquine je rappelle que le 30
mars dernier marine le pen demandé la
prescription généralisée de la
chloroquine par les médecins
généralistes pour les patients peu grave
du coc vide 19
hier on a appris que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé stopper tous les
essais cliniques sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine est ce que marine le pen
avait raison de s'engager dans ce débat
qui est finalement scientifique oui bien
sûr parce que la chloroquine pouvait
être prêt ce qui trait pourrait être
prescrite et elle l'est d'ailleurs
depuis très longtemps
les médecins ont le droit de prescrire
faut bien savoir que dans le serment
d'hippocrate vous avez ce droit de
prescription
si vous considérez qu'un médicament peut
avoir une utilité pour votre patient
vous pouvez lui prescrire donc c'est
dans ce cadre là évidemment et en
faisant confiance à la responsabilité
des médecins que marine le pen s'est
exprimée
moi je crois que derrière ça cette
histoire de clore ou qui n'ont pas
d'avis médical sur la chloroquine et
nous n'en avons pas les études qui sont
faites elles sont que soit discovery
cette fameuse étude européenne qui a du
plomb dans l aile où que ce soit la
dernière qui est elle même contestée pop
rock sur route derrière elles ont fait
naître des polémiques probablement
inutile
il ya probablement des cas dans lesquels
la prescription cantine au tout début et
à voir les hospitalisations peut avoir
du sens c'est ce que nous dit le
professeur raoul et pas de raison d'en
douter
mais je pense que derrière on a cherché
à flinguer ce grand scientifique pour
des questions qui dépassent évidemment
celle du co vide dont vous êtes derrière
le professeur raoul tu sais pas derrière
le prince saoud je suis derrière
ceux qui essayent de sauver la vie des
français et moi j'ai plutôt confiance
dans cet homme qui jusqu'à présent a
quand même donné des preuves de sa
capacité
alors justement sur la chloroquine il ya
des chefs d'états dans le monde qui
défendent également ce médicament
notamment donald trump aux états unis
jaillir bolcho narrow au brésil qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de la gestion de
cette crise par ses chefs d'état et ses
chefs d'état entre ont mal géré
visiblement d'après ce qu'on en voit par
rapport au ratio population nombre de
morts etc aux contaminations n'ont pas
pris la mesure de cette pandémie nous en
france marine le pen dès le mois de
janvier publiquement dès le mois de
février à l'assemblée
alertées les autorités d'ailleurs on
s'est moqué de nous à l'époque mais
force est de constater que bolt sonar
aurait trump qui sont et c'est
probablement la difficulté qui sont des
libéraux au fond et bien non pas pris la
mesure de cette pandémie
alors aujourd'hui les polémiques se
succèdent moi je crois que la vraie la
vraie solution les vrais bons
comportements adoptés ils ont été
prescrits par marine le pen
très tôt allez on va parler des
élections municipales puisque ça y est
la campagne du second tour peut enfin
commencer d'ici au 28 juin
cette date du 28 juin pour le second
tour visité vous étiez opposé
ce n'était pas notre option et ce
n'était pas l'option non plus j'allais
dire de richard ferrand ça traverse est
évidemment différente courant de pensée
nous pensions qu'il y avait plus de
logique à faire un grand rendez vous
démocratique en mars 2021
en reportant d'un an cette élection pour
la groupé avec les départementales pour
plusieurs raisons raisons sanitaires
protéger les français également des
raisons politiques mobiliser les
français
maintenant que la date est choisie faut
y aller donc la date est choisie faut y
aller en étant exigeant il faut que le
gouvernement se mobilise sur les raisons
les capacités sanitaires à protéger les
français sinon ils seront 1 kg et ils
n'iront pas voter
et puis il faut informer et multiplier
la possibilité de procuration parce qu
une élection qui aurait 20% d'électeurs
ne serait évidemment pas satisfaisante
on va parler de l'enjeu de ce scrutin
pour le rassemblement national
alors pour bien comprendre on va d'abord
voir les résultats du rassemblement
national au premier tour avec notamment
les maires rassemblement national
plusieurs maires et rennes ont été
réélus au premier tour on va voir cette
infographie avec notamment dans le
or le maire d'hénin-beaumont steeve
briois qui a été réélu également à
villers cotterêts dans l'aisne à hayange
en moselle
également dans le sud de la france voilà
plusieurs villes acquises aux arènes qui
vont rester rassemblement national
également béziers je précise que robert
ménard n'est pas membre du parti mais
proche du r'n ça veut dire que la
gestion des villes par le rassemblement
national a été plutôt satisfaisante
c'est la preuve par l'exemple vous savez
la réélection à 74% de steeve briois
hénin beaumont où dès le premier tour de
david rachline à fréjus ou de robert
ménard qui est un de nos partenaires et
bien montre que nos gestion municipale
elles ont été largement plébiscités on a
à peu près dix maires 8
on était sept ont été réélu dès le
premier tour donc on voit bien que notre
façon de faire fonctionne sur le terrain
et on en est très heureux il faut aller
évidemment au delà
et c'est vrai que la situation sanitaire
il faut bien le dire démobilisés
beaucoup d'électeurs parmi lesquels les
nôtres en premier
notamment dans les villes les plus
populaires et justement on va en parler
notamment des objectifs du rassemblement
national pour le second tour des
objectifs qui pourrait être un peu revu
à la baisse on va voir les villes qui
seraient gagnable au second tour par le
rassemblement national
il y à la commune de bruay la buissière
dans le pas de calais moissac dans le
tarn et garonne vauvert dans le gard
et puis une plus grande ville perpignan
avec louis aliot qui fait 35% au premier
tour ce n'était pas les objectifs de
départ du rassemblement national
les objectifs de départ c'était d'abord
conquérir des villes vous avez ici
quatre très bons exemples de villes que
nous pouvons conquérir mais également
entrer dans un maximum de conseils
municipaux puisque nous avions un
déficit d'implantation donc moi je crois
que si nous gagnons ces villes là ce
sera mission accomplie ludovic pas joe
louis aliot jean-louis maisonnée à
vauvert romain lopez à moissac sont des
candidats tout à fait sérieux et ces
villes ont besoin d'eux je note qu'à
douchy les mines avec julien franck est
à maubeuge avec aymeric merlot on a là
deux très bons candidats qui
s'implanteront sur la durée et qui vont
faire entendre une voix différente dans
des villes qui en ont besoin et donc
vous estimez que vous avez été victime
de l'abstention dans ce premier tour un
peu bizarre juste avant confinement oui
d'ailleurs c'est pas nous seuls qui
l'estimons il suffit de regarder les
chiffres
dans les villes populaires
dans les villes où il y avait des enjeux
importants et bien beaucoup d'électeurs
finalement n'y sont pas allés ils ont eu
peur ils ont probablement eu raison
d'avoir peur quand on voit le nombre de
contaminations c'est dans le nord dans
cette ville de coudekerque-branche ou 15
ac seraient responsables de bureaux de
vote ont été contaminées il y avait des
risques
donc les gens n'y sont pas allées et il
ya une prime très forte et vous l'avez
démontré avant au sortant finalement il
ya eu un coup de booster formidable pour
les maires sortants et donc par
conséquent il faut que ce second tour
qui aura lieu trois mois après et bien
ne raisonne pas comme finalement une
redite mais soit plutôt un nouveau
rendez vous électoral les choses ont
changé en trois mois et il faut que les
électeurs rassurer sécurisé puisse aller
voter un mot sur les départements des
hauts de france notamment dans le nord
dans le pas de calais la conquête qui
était prévu pour le rassemblement
national finalement elle n'a pas marché
alors la conquête en terme de deux
villes gagnées elle n'a pas peut-être
été exactement celle que nous attendions
mais en revanche nous entrons dans
tellement de conseils municipaux où nous
étions absents nous revenons par exemple
dans des grandes villes comme
saint-amand-les-eaux avec guillaume
flore qu'un nous allons rentrer
évidemment encore à jouer nous sommes
entrés dans la ville de denain etc
nous entrons et nous commençons à
structurer ce maillage territorial dont
nous avons été absents pendant de
longues années
je note d'ailleurs que nos adversaires
de en marche n'ont pas réussi leur pari
aucune grande ville n'aura été prise au
final par en marche probablement en
france
à la sortie du second tour donc voilà
c'est plutôt une élection qui a été
finalement assez stable après ce premier
tour la stabilité en mots rapidement
sébastien chenu sur votre ville
d'onnaing où vous avez été défaits dès
le premier tour comment vous l'expliquez
à bas la démobilisation l'absence de
mobilisation d'un électorat liés aux
qu'ovide a été probablement la première
source d'explication
nos électeurs et je les ai vus dans les
bureaux de vote qui nous sont
traditionnellement favorables
nos électeurs ne sont pas allés dans les
bureaux de vote qui ne nous sont pas
favorables
eh bien il eu le plein fait par le maire
sortant c'est ainsi ça fait partie du
jeu je serai avec quatre autres élus au
conseil municipal de denain jeudi pour
défendre les denaisiens vous êtes élus
de la région à des hauts de france
également est ce que vous pensez déjà
aux élections régionales en 2021
vous personnellement mais tous moi
personnellement que c'est moi je suis un
soldat discipliné
j'y pense dans la mesure où xavier
bertrand est en échec dans cette région
c'est un homme de communication c'est un
homme de droite
c'est un peu le candidat des des
chambres de commerce et qui n'a pas
démontré sa capacité à solutionner le
chômage à redynamiser notre région il
était en échec également là encore sur
la distribution de masques ça se passe
pas bien parce que faire de la
communication
c'est une chose résoudre les problèmes
des gens sont là est une autre et ça n'a
pas fonctionné avec xavier bertrand et
marine le pen serait la bonne candidate
pour une revanche de 2015 aux régionales
l'an prochain non je crois qu'il faut
pas être dans un esprit de revanche
je crois qu'il faut proposer un autre
chemin c'est marine le pen souhaite
s'engager
nous en serons très heureux je crois que
ce n'était pas son soir elle avait
indiqué elle sera évidemment présente
dans cette campagne des régionales on va
finir par une dernière question qui
concerne les violences policières et la
polémique autour de la chanteuse camélia
jordana qui a affirmé ce week-end sur un
plateau de télévision je cite en parlant
de ces français qui se font massacrer
pour nulle autre horizon que leur
couleur de peau
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a dénoncé ces propos mais il ne
veut pas entamer de poursuites
judiciaires
qu'en pensez vous oui ministre de
l'intérieur a toujours un peu la main la
main molle lorsqu'il s'agit de défendre
ses propres troupes
moi je me suis posé la question camélia
jordana est elle une conne tout
simplement et ses propos des pastels sa
pensée ou est-elle une militante
politique anti républicaine anti flics
et je pense que c'est ça le problème
c'est que c'est une militante politique
qui a des propos qui vise à déconstruire
et à faire passer notre police nationale
police de la république pour ce qu'elle
n'est pas donc elle doit être poursuivie
c'est en tous les cas la nécessité
correa christophe castaner à le faire
c'est aussi la possibilité que des
syndicats de police puissent enclencher
ces poursuites parce qu'ils sont
inadmissibles
notre police est exemplaire une bavure
elle est sanctionnée immédiatement quand
elle est quand elle existe elle ne doit
pas exister dans un état évidemment
républicain mais ces propos sont
inadmissibles
merci beaucoup sébastien chenu d'avoir
été notre avait notre invité politique
ce matin sur le plateau de bonjour chez
vous et demain à votre place
ce sera françois patriat le président du
groupe la république en marche au sénat